Katrina: 那烤肉调料可以上上烤架了是吗
Katrina: Can we put the barbecue seasoning on the grill?
Shure: 可以的可以的
Shure: Yes, you can
Katrina: OK把他们喊出来
Katrina: OK, call them over
Katrina: 他们说可以出去了
Katrina: They said we can go out now
Katrina: 那把肉拿出去
Katrina: Then take the meat out
Katrina: 不会的
Katrina: 对啊我们6个人
Katrina: 还要把那盆肉给端出来
Katrina: 这两个摄像头
Jake:可以开始烤了
Katrina: 没有任何感触
Katrina: No feelings at all
Katrina: 就是觉得好爽
Katrina: Just feels so good
Katrina: 在这过养老生活
Katrina: Living a retirement life here.
Katrina: 咋了
Katrina: What's up?
Katrina: 搞点北冰洋
Katrina: Let's get some Arctic Ocean soda.
Katrina: 我去把北冰洋拿下来
Katrina: 2122吧好像
Katrina: I think it's 2122.
Katrina: 现在把饮料拿下来
Katrina: 给你看看我们住的地方
Katrina: 我住在2楼
Katrina: I live on the 2nd floor.
Katrina: 到处都有摄像头
Katrina: There are cameras everywhere.
Katrina: 看见没有
Katrina: Do you see them?
Katrina: 就是这种
Katrina: Just like this one.
Katrina: 到处都是电脑
Katrina: There are computers everywhere.
Katrina: 这我的房间
Katrina: This is my room.
Katrina: 北冰洋放哪里了
Katrina: Where did you put the Arctic Ocean soda?
Katrina: 番茄酱烤肉
Katrina: Tomato sauce barbecue.
Katrina: 哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒
Katrina: Da da da da da da da da da.
Katrina: 拿玻璃杯还是拿一次性杯呢
Katrina: 拿玻璃杯吧
Katrina: Let's use glass cups.
Katrina: 玻璃杯好看一点
Katrina: Glass cups look nicer.
Katrina: 就拿这个吧
Katrina: Let's just use this one.
Katrina: 这可以直接喝
Katrina: You can drink this directly.
Katrina: 需要兑东西吗
Katrina: Do we need to mix it with something?
Shure: 就是今天买那个吗
Shure: Is this the one we bought today?
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yes.
Shure: 对直接喝就行
Shure: Yeah, you can drink it directly.
Shure: 然后你觉得不行你再兑东西
Shure: And if you don't like it, you can mix it with something.
Katrina: ok
Katrina: 拜拜
Tasha: 进入完全不讲究状态
Tasha: Entering a completely careless state.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Katrina: 这是什么
Katrina: What's this?
Katrina: 咖啡豆啊
Katrina: Coffee beans?
Tasha: 呃巧克力
Tasha: Uh, chocolate.
Lucia: 巧克力啊没事不用对不起
Lucia: Chocolate, it's fine, no need to apologize.
Katrina: 哦哦对不起
Katrina: Oh, sorry.
Katrina: 巧克力
Katrina: Chocolate.
Alice:小火慢炖的
Alice: It's slow-cooked.
Katrina: 哈哈哈我
Katrina: Hahaha, I...
Katrina: 我的生活常识太匮乏
Katrina: My life skills are really lacking.
Katrina: 这能扔了不
Katrina: Can I throw this away?
Katrina: 感觉第一天
Katrina: Feels like the first day.
Lucia: 宇轩要先吃一片吗
Lucia: Does Yuxuan want to try a piece first?
Katrina: 我尝一个
Katrina: I'll try one.
Lucia: 喂你吧要不哈哈哈
Lucia: Feed you? Haha
Katrina: 好的你喂我吧
Katrina: Okay, you feed me then.
Lucia: 健康要先吃一片吗
Lucia: Should we start with a piece for health?
Jake:好好
Jake: Sure, sure.
Lucia: 我就不喂你了
Lucia: I won't feed you then.
Lucia: 自己可以给你倒出来哈哈
Lucia: You can pour it yourself, haha.
Katrina: 嗯这个真好吃
Lucia: 哎呀我再来一片
Lucia: Oh, I'll have another piece.
Jake:这是什么呀
Jake: What is this?
Jake:这叫什么呀
Jake: What's this called?
Katrina: 巧克力嗯这个巧克力好香
Tasha: 一定要认准这个牌子
Tasha: You have to recognize this brand.
Alice:可以多放点
Alice: You can add more.
Tasha: 百丽
Tasha: Belle.
Tasha: 天呐
Tasha: Oh my god.
Jake:嗯确实不太好端
Jake: Yeah, it's really hard to hold.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Lucia: 哈哈哈他突然文盲哈哈哈哈不不不
Lucia: Haha, he suddenly became illiterate, haha, no no no.
Tasha: 不愧是高材生
Tasha: As expected of a top student.
Katrina: 哇塞
Katrina: 惠灵顿牛排
Katrina: Wellington steak.
Katrina: 再拿两个杯子
Katrina: Grab two more cups.
Lucia: 没有就有一回
Lucia: There was only one time.
Tasha: 就是切切的刀上面有蒜味
Tasha: The knife we used to cut has a garlic smell.
Lucia: 我们家里忘记对我们家切过蒜的刀
Lucia: We forgot, we used our knife for garlic.
Jake:哦哦切刀刀上哦
Jake: Oh, oh, the knife, oh.
Katrina: 这个要洗
Katrina: This needs to be washed.
Katrina: 但这怎么洗啊
Katrina: But how to wash it?
Katrina: 冲一下吗泡一下
Katrina: Rinse it? Soak it?
Jake:用什么东西泡呀
Jake: Soak it in what?
Tasha: 这肉
Tasha: This meat.
Katrina: 就是
Tasha: 您来
Tasha: You do it.
Katrina: 这怎么洗嘞
Katrina: How do you wash this?
Lucia: 嗯我试试看
Lucia: Hmm, I'll give it a try.
Katrina: 我好像不会洗青菜
Katrina: I don't really know how to wash vegetables.
Katrina: 就是
Katrina: I mean...
Katrina: 我的认知里好像没有洗青菜这个选
Katrina: I don't think washing vegetables is in my knowledge base.
Lucia: 生菜确实一般
Lucia: Lettuce is usually...
Lucia: 可能都直接在这放一下好了
Lucia: Maybe just put it here for a bit.
Lucia: 哎小心吃会不会那个会不会烫
Lucia: Hey, be careful. Will it be hot?
Lucia: 我也不知道
Lucia: I don't know either.
Lucia: 咱要不把它
Lucia: Should we...
Lucia: 都掰开吧
Lucia: Break it all apart?
Katrina: 嗯应该是掰开了
Katrina: Hmm, should be broken apart.
Katrina: 然后一片片水洗一下冲一下
Katrina: Then wash each piece with water.
Lucia: 找个盘子
Lucia: Find a plate.
Katrina: 然后还要干嘛来着
Katrina: Then what else?
Katrina: 哦还要拿两个杯子
Katrina: Oh, get two cups too.
Lucia: 把盘拿大点的
Lucia: Get a bigger plate.
Lucia: 盘子这盘
Lucia: This plate.
Lucia: 不过这盘子还没用过
Lucia: But we haven't used this plate yet.
Jake:我先少弄点啊
Jake: I'll just do a little bit first.
Tasha: 啊好
Tasha: Ah, okay.
Jake:好我保守一点保守一点
Jake: Okay, I'll be a bit conservative.
Tasha: 这个有点多了吧
Tasha: This seems like too much.
Tasha: 不是很保守吗
Tasha: Isn't this too conservative?
Jake:哈哈确实
Jake: Haha, indeed.
Katrina: 我们之间的回忆
Katrina: Our memories together.
Lucia: 你干了什么
Lucia: What did you do?
Jake:还好还好就是呃呃尽量让他均匀
Jake: It's alright, just try to make it even.
Jake:但是可能没那么均匀
Jake: But it might not be that even.
Tasha: 你看第一个和这个均匀吗
Tasha: Does the first one look even with this one?
Jake:哎一会再补一补啊补一补
Jake: Hey, we'll fix it up a bit later.
Lucia: 你做了什么伤天害理的事
Lucia: What terrible thing did you do?
Tasha: 这个这个这个
Tasha: This, this, this.
Katrina: 有多的镊子吗
Katrina: Do we have extra tweezers?
Katrina: 要我帮你吗
Katrina: Do you want my help?
Katrina: 有点想烤哦
Katrina: I kind of want to bake.
Katrina: 在拿筷子是吧
Katrina: You're getting chopsticks, right?
Shure: 嗯里面再拿双筷子
Shure: Yeah, get another pair of chopsticks from inside.
Lucia: 这么大厨房我觉得两三个人还行
Lucia: In a kitchen this big, two or three people are okay.
Lucia: 再多就东西会放不下
Lucia: Any more and we won't have enough space for everything.
Tasha: 还有十几分钟这我就烤好了
Tasha: In a little over ten minutes, this will be baked.
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: Wow.
Lucia: 那咱外面的进度咋样
Lucia: How's the progress outside?
Shure: 把盖把把盖拔下来
Shure: Take off the cover.
Alice:筷子呢
Alice: Where are the chopsticks?
Shure: 筷子在他手
Shure: The chopsticks are in his hand.
Katrina: 我要我要
Katrina: I want them, I want them.
Katrina: 咋了我要证明我自己
Katrina: What’s up? I want to prove myself.
Katrina: 生气了
Katrina: I'm mad.
Katrina: 就是镊子不好用吗
Katrina: Are the tweezers not working?
Katrina: 我再去拿一个
Katrina: 这应该是无意义的跑来跑去
Katrina: 应该用那种蜂窝
Katrina: We should use that honeycomb one.
Katrina: 蜂窝的那个
Katrina: The honeycomb one.
Jake:应该是
Jake: That should be it.
Lucia: 它接触氧的面积会比较大一点
Lucia: It will have a larger surface area exposed to oxygen.
Katrina: 耶
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina: 只剩一只筷子了
Katrina: There's only one chopstick left.
Jake:一只筷子
Jake: A single chopstick
Katrina: 哎我们只有这几双筷子
Katrina: Hey, we only have these few pairs of chopsticks
Lucia: 我也好奇
Lucia: 你的那个
Lucia: 哎还行吧
Lucia: Hey, it's okay
Lucia: 你是刚才就是再分配了一下吗
Jake:对对对再分配
Jake: Yeah, yeah, redistributed
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Tasha: 二次分配
Tasha: Second distribution
Jake:哈哈哈是的
Jake: Hahaha, yes
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah
Jake:就和谐了嘛
Jake: It's harmonious now
Jake:现在很和谐
Jake: Very harmonious now
Jake:看看好现在全面脱贫
Jake: Look, now we've eradicated poverty
Jake:哈哈哈可以吧
Jake: Hahaha, is that okay?
Katrina: 哈哈哈笑死
Katrina: Hahaha, that's hilarious
Jake:怎么样和谐
Jake: How's that for harmony?
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Good
Lucia: 可以非常好
Lucia: It's very good
Tasha: 你看有的很好
Tasha: You see, some are really good
Jake:啊还是有一些先富的人是吧
Jake: Ah, there are still some who got rich first, right?
Katrina: 了
Katrina: Yeah
Lucia: 哎我觉得里面的这些叶子很干净
Lucia: Hey, I think the leaves inside are very clean
Tasha: 不
Tasha: No
Tasha: 不是你看这上面有很多气泡看到了吗
Tasha: No, look, there are a lot of bubbles on top, can you see them?
Tasha: 啊就这样子
Tasha: Ah, just like that
Jake:哦那我每个都打一会
Jake: Oh, then I'll stir each one for a while
Tasha: 就是因为你可能弄得太低了
Tasha: It's because you might have set it too low
Katrina: 我带我的筷子来了
Katrina: I brought my chopsticks
Shure: 感觉差不多
Shure: Looks about right
Shure: 就翻一翻
Shure: Just flip it
Shure: 一分钟翻一次就行
Shure: Flip it once every minute
Katrina: 还是他没燃
Katrina: 有一种早期那种围炉取暖的感觉
Katrina: It feels like the old days, warming up around a stove
Katrina: 很爽特别这边还特别安静
Katrina: Very nice, especially since it's so quiet here
Lucia: 这个菜现在用得到吗
Lucia: Do we need this dish now?
Lucia: 如果暂时用不到我就先放回去
Lucia: If we don't need it for now, I'll put it back.
Lucia: 一会再拿出来
Lucia: We can take it out later.
Katrina: 你可以放桌上呢
Katrina: You can put it on the table.
Lucia: 桌上我怕外面灰大一会就
Lucia: I'm afraid it'll get dusty outside.
Katrina: 啊那放里面吧
Katrina: Ah, then put it inside.
Katrina: 现在感觉还没熟呢
Katrina: It doesn't seem fully cooked yet.
Shure: 离熟还有点距离
Shure: It's still a bit undercooked.
Shure: 放下放下
Shure: Put it down, put it down.
Shure: 再烧一会
Shure: Cook it a bit longer.
Shure: 拿两个盘出来
Shure: Take out two plates.
Shure: 拿三个吧
Shure: Actually, take out three.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Okay.
Tasha: 哎我靠
Tasha: Oh my gosh.
Tasha: 呃没必要
Tasha: Uh, it's not necessary.
Tasha: 可以了可以了
Tasha: It's okay, it's okay.
Tasha: 干嘛呢接下来
Tasha: What are we doing next?
Jake:不不有气泡
Jake: No, no, there are bubbles.
Tasha: 真没必要了
Tasha: It's really unnecessary.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:哈这为什么感觉有
Jake: Haha, why does it look like...
Jake:有红的颜色
Jake: There's a red color.
Jake:是这个油
Jake: Is it this oil?
Tasha: 巧克力可能溶溶了一些可以了
Tasha: The chocolate might have melted a bit, it's fine.
Jake:你看这个是气泡吧
Jake: Look, these are bubbles, right?
Lucia: 这哪里有红的
Lucia: Where's the red?
Lucia: 您绝对色感也太好了吧
Lucia: Your color perception is amazing.
Jake:哈哈哈哈有这种夸赞吗
Jake: Hahaha, is this a compliment?
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈你是不是想说这么明显
Lucia: Hahaha, are you trying to say it's so obvious?
Jake:不是不是我说有这种夸赞
Jake: No, no, I mean, such praise.
Lucia: 哈哈哈是啊
Lucia: Hahaha, yeah.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:不是就是
Jake: No, I mean...
Lucia: 真是一种夸赞
Lucia: It really is a compliment.
Lucia: 你学画画很厉害的
Lucia: You're really good at drawing.
Lucia: 会哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha, yeah.
Jake:好这么回事
Jake: Alright, I get it.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:可能是我这个眼线的反射
Jake: Maybe it's the reflection of my eyeliner.
Katrina: 放哪
Shure: 放桌上吧先
Shure: Just put it on the table first.
Shure: 太牛了
Shure: 炭烧透了
Shure: The charcoal is thoroughly burned.
Shure: 人类的一小步
Shure: One small step for mankind.
Alice:这是碳
Shure: 没事还没碰到呢
Shure: It's okay, it hasn't touched yet.
Shure: 碰到了你也就当刚刚没有看到好吧
Shure: If it touches, just pretend you didn't see it, alright?
Shure: 是的说犒劳老板
Shure: Yeah, to reward the boss.
Shure: 老板的命不能让他是命
Shure: The boss's life can't be treated like this.
Katrina: 我来
Katrina: I'll do it.
Katrina: 我要何时再回首
Katrina: When will I look back again?
Katrina: 直接烤成维吾尔族了
Katrina: Roasted directly into Uyghur style. 种族宗教问题
Shure: OK最后一块
Shure: OK, the last piece.
Shure: 牛逼把他们全叫来了
Shure: Awesome, you called them all over.
Shure: 真够烤的这羊排
Shure: This lamb chop is really well roasted.
Shure: 薄的这个我感觉可以拿出来
Shure: The thin one, I think we can take it out.
Shure: 就这一个是没问题的
Shure: 小心那个别碰到那铁烫
Lucia: 这个辣椒面和那个芝麻
Lucia: This chili powder and sesame.
Lucia: 如果需要撒的话
Lucia: If you need to sprinkle, go ahead.
Katrina: 没有进展
Katrina: 正在等待中哈哈
Katrina: Waiting, haha.
Shure: 就是没灯
Shure: There's no light.
Shure: 说实话你问问杨老板
Shure: Honestly, ask Jake.
Shure: 能不能想办法给这补个光
Shure: See if he can figure out how to add some lighting here.
Katrina: 哦把那个大灯拿过来
Shure: 但是那个需要供电啊
Shure: But that needs a power supply.
Katrina: 搞个那个插线板
Katrina: Get a power strip.
Katrina: 从他这个窗户这拿出来
Katrina: Run it out from this window.
Lucia: 应该没那么长
Katrina: 嗯对对对
Alice:你这玩意随便一摆吧
Katrina: okok
Katrina: 英雄终于有用武之地了
Katrina: Finally, a chance for the hero to shine.
Shure: 火越来越旺了越来越滋滋冒油了
Katrina: 嗯嗯再来一个牛排
Shure: 牛排
Alice:这羊排
Shure: 我去我去
Shure: I'll go, I'll go.
Shure: 我去厨房先给大家煎俩牛排吃
Shure: I'll go to the kitchen and cook a couple of steaks for everyone.
Alice:我们家就总在阳台上烤肉吃
Katrina: 哎可以了可以了
Katrina: Hey, that's good, that's good.
Katrina: 嘉玲可以听见吗
Katrina: Jia Ling, can you hear us?
Katrina: 你你能共享屏幕给我们看一下吗
Katrina: Can you share your screen with us?
Katrina: 嗯嗯
Katrina: Uh-huh.
Katrina: 可以可以
Katrina: Yeah, that's good.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina: 是你那一篇就是
Katrina: Is it that one paper of yours?
Katrina: 嗯你不知道创新
Katrina: Hmm, you know, the innovative part?
Katrina: 就是你那个创新点
Katrina: The one the teacher rejected?
Katrina: 被老师否定的那个吗
Katrina: I'm still experimenting on that.
Katrina: 嗯那这篇呢
Katrina: Hmm, and this paper?
Katrina: 这篇能投什么
Katrina: Where can you submit it?
Katrina: 有老师带吗
Katrina: Do you have a mentor?
Katrina: 就自己写的
Katrina: You wrote them yourself?
Katrina: 那怎么投呢到时候
Shure: 好了好了快快快叫出来叫出来
Katrina: 啊你打算自己投是吧
Katrina: 那你这个创新点
Katrina: So, this innovative point.
Katrina: 是自己看论文然后想的吗找的吗
Katrina: Did you come up with it by reading papers?
Katrina: 那就是找那种机构帮你发是吧
Katrina: Are you going to get some organization to help you publish it?
Katrina: 嗯然后你得你得稍微去了解一下
Katrina: Hmm, you should look into it a bit.
Katrina: 能不能赶上夏令营
Katrina: See if you can make it to the summer camp.
Katrina: 然后然后
Katrina: And then...
Katrina: 然后就是
Katrina: And then
Katrina: 如果他们给你报那个呃EI会议的名字
Katrina: If they give you the name of the EI conference
Katrina: 你最好也去查一下哈
Katrina: You'd better check it out yourself
Katrina: 因为有的那个机构
Katrina: Because some organizations
Katrina: 他给的会议不是特别好
Katrina: Their conferences aren't particularly good
Katrina: 你这个是做什么的呀
Katrina: What is your current paper about?
Katrina: 就现在这个论文
Katrina: This paper you're working on now
Katrina: 这是你当时是谁给你的idea和题目啊
Katrina: Who gave you the idea and topic for this at the time?
Katrina: 哦你现在写完了吗
Katrina: Oh, have you finished writing it?
Katrina: 你这个有跑实验吗
Katrina: Did you do any experiments for this?
Katrina: 给我看看你往下翻
Katrina: 嗯你对YOLO V5模型有改进吗
Katrina: Did you make any improvements to the YOLO V5 model?
Katrina: 改进了什么
Katrina: What did you improve?
Katrina: 加了它的模块吗
Katrina: Did you add any modules?
Katrina: 哪个性能比别的模型要好呀
Katrina: Which one performs better than other models?
Katrina: 准确率吗
Katrina: The accuracy?
Katrina: 嗯看看
Katrina: Hmm, let's see
Katrina: 那就是这个论文你是要投是吧
Katrina: So, you're submitting this paper, right?
Katrina: 然后那一篇论文就
Katrina: Then that paper, how far is the experiment?
Katrina: 实验进展到哪一步了
Katrina: How's the progress?
Katrina: 你是说你说手上这个吗
Katrina: 还是说那个晚安的那个
Katrina: Or the goodnight one?
Katrina: 你那个老师是教授吗
Katrina: Is your teacher a professor?
Katrina: 嗯我想想可以也
Katrina: Hmm, let me think, that's possible too.
Katrina: 也可以
Katrina: That works too.
Katrina: 那你现在的idea和创新点有确定吗
Katrina: 就是
Katrina: Exactly.
Katrina: 只要你那个整体的思路
Katrina: As long as your overall idea...
Katrina: 然后包括老师也认可你的idea
Katrina: And the teacher also approves of your idea.
Katrina: 然后你就可以把它包装成一个
Katrina: Then you can package it into a...
Katrina: 呃项目经历
Katrina: Uh, project experience.
Katrina: 然后套词的时候也好说就
Katrina: Then when you phrase it, it will be easier to say.
Katrina: 毕竟你是自己做的
Katrina: After all, you did it yourself.
Katrina: 应该会就是回答问题会比较流利
Katrina: You should be able to answer questions more fluently.
Katrina: 那就还行
Katrina: That would be okay.
Katrina: 那个是做什么的呀呃
Katrina: What is it for, uh...
Katrina: 你说你介绍一下
Katrina: Tell us about it.
Katrina: 刚刚那个是做什么的
Katrina: What was that just now?
Katrina: 就是那个没投出去的那个
Katrina: The one that didn't get voted on.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yes.
Katrina: 那个你跟我们讲一下别人的工作
Katrina: Can you tell us about other people's work?
Katrina: 一般你要解决什么问题
Katrina: What kind of problems do you usually solve?
Katrina: 别人是怎么做的
Katrina: How do others do it?
Katrina: 然后你们的创新点是什么
Katrina: And what's your innovation?
Katrina: 然后然后什么上表现比较好
Katrina: What are the areas where you excel?
Katrina: 那你就是先说前面三部分吧
Katrina: So just talk about the first three parts.
Katrina: 好
Katrina: Okay.
Katrina: 前面三个就是你要解决一个什么问题
Katrina: The first three parts are about what problem you want to solve.
Katrina: 就是有的老师坐在下面的评委老师
Katrina: There are some teachers in the audience as judges.
Katrina: 他不一定懂你
Katrina: They might not understand you.
Katrina: 这个区就是领域
Katrina: This area, this field.
Katrina: 所以你要就是相当于你
Katrina: So you need to, it's like you're selling something.
Katrina: 相当于你去做销售一样
Katrina: It's like you're doing sales.
Katrina: 你要通俗的
Katrina: You need to be simple.
Katrina: 去流利的介绍你做的这个东西
Katrina: Introduce what you do fluently.
Katrina: 让别人能懂
Katrina: Make sure others understand.
Katrina: 然后并且显得很高级
Katrina: And make it look sophisticated.
Katrina: 你可以先跟我们就不用那么简洁的讲
Katrina: You can explain it to us in a less simplified way.
Katrina: 就是详细的讲一下
Katrina: Just explain it in detail.
Katrina: 那你那个呃
Katrina: So you...
Katrina: 就是也没有写东西
Katrina: So, you didn't write anything.
Katrina: 所以你也不能展示是吧
Katrina: So you can't show it, right?
Katrina: 作业呢还没写
Katrina: The homework isn't done yet.
Katrina: 嗯那你这学期还有比赛吗
Katrina: So, do you have any competitions this semester?
Katrina: 那就是忙这两篇论文是吧
Katrina: 然后你们这学期的专业必修课还多吗
Katrina: And do you have a lot of required courses this semester?
Katrina: 啊那你现在机事复习到哪一步了
Katrina: So, how far along are you with your preparations?
Katrina: 嗯嗯那就是这篇论文
Katrina: Yeah, so it's this paper.
Katrina: 你预计能什么时候写完
Katrina: When do you think you can finish writing?
Katrina: 就屏幕共享的这个
Katrina: The one you're screen sharing.
Katrina: 这这周末前吗
Katrina: Before this weekend?
Katrina: OK然后那个实验呢
Katrina: OK, and what about the experiment?
Katrina: 哦下周
Katrina: Oh, next week.
Katrina: 那那那个实验呢
Katrina: What about that experiment?
Katrina: 就是就不确定是吧
Katrina: So it's not certain, right?
Katrina: 嗯但是那也还好
Katrina: Yeah, but that's alright.
Katrina: 就是你下周把这嗯
Katrina: So, next week...
Katrina: 就差不多4月底吧
Katrina: Around the end of April.
Katrina: 就5月前把这篇论文给投出去
Katrina: Submit this paper before May.
Katrina: 然后然后5月份的时候
Katrina: And then in May...
Katrina: 重心就是
Katrina: The focus is...
Katrina: 其实也就两件事
Katrina: Actually just two things.
Katrina: 一个是复习
Katrina: One is revising.
Katrina: 一个就是忙
Katrina: The other is...
Katrina: 那个实验嘛
Katrina: The experiment.
Katrina: 其实还是忙的过来的
Katrina: It's still manageable.
Katrina: 嗯然后我就大概明白了
Katrina: Yeah, I get it.
Katrina: 然后
Katrina: And then...
Katrina: 嗯到时候我帮你改简历的话
Katrina: When I help you revise your resume...
Katrina: 这两天先帮你改这篇文章的
Katrina: Let me help you revise this paper first.
Katrina: 然后那个的话还是先空着
Katrina: 然后你也要大概组织一下语言哈
Katrina: 然后其他的我没什么问题
Katrina: 你问问学长有没有什么建议
Katrina: 嗯没事
Katrina: 就是我我这边看到的就是他这学期
Katrina: 嗯没有比赛
Katrina: Hmm, no competition.
Katrina: 然后专业必修课也比较少
Katrina: And there are also fewer required courses.
Katrina: 然后就是复习加上手上这两篇论文
Katrina: So, it's just reviewing and working on these two papers.
Katrina: 然后他现在展示的这一篇论文呢
Katrina: And the paper he's presenting now...
Katrina: 是自己写的
Katrina: He wrote it himself.
Katrina: 就是一个可能本科做的一个项目
Katrina: It's probably a project from his undergrad.
Katrina: 然后打算自己去投一篇EI
Katrina: And he's planning to submit it to EI.
Katrina: 就是没有老师带的
Katrina: Without a professor's guidance.
Katrina: 然后在下周前估计能写完
Katrina: And he expects to finish it by next week.
Katrina: 然后第二个就是他老师带
Katrina: And the second one is guided by his professor.
Katrina: 他那个创新点
Katrina: That was his innovative point.
Katrina: 前一段时间不是被否定了吗
Katrina: Wasn't it rejected a while ago?
Katrina: 然后实验还在跑
Katrina: And the experiment is still running.
Katrina: 但是他的创新点
Katrina: But his innovation point...
Katrina: 和那个总体的实验方法是确定的
Katrina: The overall experiment method is confirmed.
Katrina: 所以就这两个
Katrina: So just these two.
Katrina: 然后我给他的建议就是忙这两篇论文
Katrina: And my suggestion to him is to focus on these two papers.
Katrina: 5月 5月前忙完这篇论文
Katrina: Finish this paper by May.
Katrina: 然后之后5月就是要忙他的复习
Katrina: Then after May, he needs to focus on his reviews.
Katrina: 和那一篇
Katrina: And that one.
Katrina: 两个县城并行
Katrina: Two counties in parallel.
Katrina: 我觉得还是能够忙得过来的
Katrina: I think he can manage it.
Katrina: 然后我主要就是知道一下
Katrina: And I mainly just want to know.
Katrina: 他论文的大概内容和档次就行
Katrina: The general content and level of his paper.
Katrina: 到时候看
Katrina: We'll see then.
Katrina: 如果是他自己投机构的话
Katrina: If he submits it to an institution himself.
Katrina: 可能那边也要对接一下
Katrina: Maybe over there, they need to connect too.
Katrina: 跟那个你要投什么会议
Katrina: And what conference you want to submit to.
Katrina: 可能那边也会有自己的格式吧
Katrina: Maybe they also have their own format.
Katrina: 嗯那等他把这个主题全部写完
Katrina: Well, wait for him to finish writing the whole topic.
Katrina: 再跳格式吧
Katrina: Then we'll adjust the format.
Katrina: 嗯那其他我没啥问题
Katrina: Well, I don't have any other issues.
Katrina: 我现在大概了解了他的那个经历
Katrina: Now I roughly understand his experience.
Katrina: 嗯好
Katrina: Alright.
Katrina: 我现在明白
Katrina: I get it now.
Katrina: 就没啥问题
Katrina: There's no problem.
Katrina: 你你有什么问题要问我们吗
Katrina: Do you have any questions for us?
Katrina: 你那个第二篇论文的实验
Katrina: Your experiment for the second paper...
Katrina: 做到哪一步了
Katrina: How far have you gotten?
Katrina: 就是模型在跑吗
Katrina: Is the model running?
Katrina: 数据集是自己弄的
Katrina: Did you make the dataset yourself?
Katrina: 模型在跑
Katrina: The model is running.
Katrina: 行那就这样
Katrina: Alright, that'll do.
Katrina: 你就把这篇论文把它投出去
Katrina: Just submit this paper.
Katrina: 因为这个最好改一下时改一下
Katrina: It’s best to make some revisions.
Katrina: 夏令营嘛
Katrina: It's for the summer camp.
Katrina: 你把这个弄完了以后嗯
Katrina: Once you finish this, yeah...
Katrina: 就去套词吧
Katrina: Just go for the submission.
Katrina: 嗯然后到时候我帮你把简历弄一下
Katrina: And then I'll help you with your resume.
Katrina: 就行了
Katrina: That's all.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina: 那还有其他的
Katrina: Any other...
Katrina: 还有啥问题不
Katrina: Any other questions?
Katrina: 好的好的
Katrina: Alright, alright.
Katrina: 先到这吧
Katrina: Let's leave it at this for now.
Katrina: 拜拜拜拜
Katrina: Bye bye, bye bye.
Katrina: 这是在做什么
Katrina: What are you doing?
Jake:再切蛋糕再分层
Jake: Cutting the cake into layers.
Katrina: 切蛋糕哇
Katrina: Cutting the cake, wow.
Lucia: 好耶
Lucia: Yay!
Jake:再来一层
Jake: Another layer.
Lucia: 这真的还够再切一层吗
Lucia: Can we really cut another layer?
Tasha: 你看这一层多厚啊
Tasha: Look how thick this layer is!
Lucia: 再再切太薄了
Lucia: Cut, cut it thinner.
Lucia: 别别别又给最后
Lucia: No, no, no, it'll be the last one.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 我们做出来一个pancake是吧哈哈
Lucia: We'll end up making a pancake, right? Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈可以
Jake: Hahaha, it's possible.
Tasha: 哈可以吗
Katrina: Ha, is it possible?
Jake:可以
Jake:好可以吧
Jake: Okay, shall we?
Lucia: 杨老板这么自信肯定能签好
Jake: With Jake being so confident, it'll definitely turn out well.
Jake:姚老板这么自信肯定能切好
Jake:等一下我再测一下
Jake: Wait a second, let me check again.
Katrina: 我去帮他们外面
Jake:这可以吧
Jake: Is this okay?
Lucia: 我不知道啊
Lucia: I don't know.
Lucia: 你看你得问
Lucia: Look, you need to ask.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Katrina: wow i'm coming back
Katrina: Wow, I'm coming back.
Shure: 来来子轩
Shure: Come on, Zixuan.
Katrina: 哇
Katrina: Wow.
Shure: 不不不呸
Shure: No, no, no, yuck.
Katrina: 叫什么哈哈尝尝是吗
Katrina: What do you call it, haha, taste it, right?
Shure: 雨轩雨轩雨轩
Shure: Yuxuan, Yuxuan, Yuxuan.
Shure: 先吃先吃咱
Shure: Let's eat first, let's eat.
Katrina: 给你拍照
Katrina: I'll take a picture for you.
Shure: 偷偷吃不等他们了
Shure: Eat secretly, don't wait for them.
Shure: 叫我半天不来吃
Shure: Calling me for so long, not coming to eat.
Katrina: 他们在里面可
Katrina: They are inside...
Shure: 我靠你直接一块全啃了是吧
Shure: Whoa, you just ate the whole thing, didn't you?
Alice:就可以拿下来了
Alice: You can take it down now.
Shure: 好
Katrina: 嗯好好吃
Katrina: Hmm, it's delicious.
Alice:怎么样
Alice: How is it?
Katrina: 忒香了
Katrina: It's super tasty.
Jake:嗯好好吃
Alice:这是生的那个那个
Katrina: 他们在切蛋糕
Shure: 肥一点的是吗
Shure: You want the fattier one?
Katrina: 旋转跳跃我不会
Katrina: I can't spin and jump.
Katrina: 这是羊肉是吧
Katrina: This is lamb, right?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 来主厨请
Shure: Come on, chef, please.
Katrina: 你去拿个垃圾桶出来吧
Katrina: Can you go grab a trash can?
Lucia: 下面能吃了吗
Lucia: Can we eat now?
Katrina: 可以出去吧
Katrina: Can we go out now?
Lucia: 啊太好了
Lucia: Ah, that's great.
Jake:我也要吃
Katrina: 一人一个腿呀
Katrina: Everyone gets a leg, okay?
Jake:还有吗还有吗还有吗还有吗
Jake: Is there more, is there more, is there more?
Katrina: 有
Jake:这么大
Jake:哦这个可以吧
Jake: Oh, this one should be fine.
Jake:一般是多大
Jake: Usually, how big is it?
Shure: 都可以都可以吃吧
Shure: It's all good, we can eat it all.
Jake:行行行试试
Jake: Okay, okay, let's try it.
Shure: 晚来反正就没有
Katrina: 来口啤酒吗
Shure: 给你倒点尝尝
Shure: Let me pour you some to try.
Katrina: 啤酒不好喝
Lucia: 啊终于好了是吗
Lucia: Ah, it's finally done, right?
Alice:我感觉我们可能吃不完
Alice: I feel like we might not be able to finish it.
Alice:这碳就烧没了
Alice: The charcoal is almost burned out.
Shure: 他说能烧5-6个小时啊
Shure: He said it could burn for 5-6 hours.
Shure: 真不来点吗
Shure: Are you sure you don't want some?
Katrina: 你给我倒一点点
Katrina: Pour me a little bit.
Katrina: 这啤酒很好喝哎行
Katrina: This beer is really good, okay.
Shure: 不
Shure: No.
Shure: 撸一个串
Shure: Have a skewer.
Shure: 然后再喝一个啤酒
Shure: Then have a beer.
Shure: 他很好喝
Shure: It's really good.
Katrina: 哼哼哼
Katrina: Hmm-hmm-hmm.
Shure: 他绝对无敌
Shure: It's absolutely unbeatable.
Shure: 人到齐了吗
Shure: Is everyone here?
Shure: 人到齐把香槟开了
Shure: Let's open the champagne when everyone is here.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 等会我们坐里面
Lucia: Wait a minute, let's sit inside.
Jake:干羊排
Jake: Dry lamb chop
Shure: 那羊排谁没吃着
Shure: Who didn't get the lamb chop?
Shure: 然后把那一块都吃了吧
Shure: Let's just eat that piece then.
Katrina: 谁没吃
Shure: 来录录一个开香槟
Shure: Let's record opening the champagne.
Katrina: 准备就绪
Katrina: Ready to go.
Shure: 真就绪了吗
Shure: Really ready?
Jake:我再拿个灯下来吧
Jake: I'll get another light down.
Jake:我这边也打掉
Jake: I'll turn this one off too.
Lucia: 嗯好
Lucia: Okay, got it.
Shure: 而且这个室室外这圈灯不亮了
Shure: Also, the lights outside aren't on.
Shure: 你没发现吗
Shure: Did you notice?
Jake:哎为啥呀
Jake: Hey, why's that?
Alice:没有刀吗
Alice: No knife?
Jake:灯被我抢了
Jake: I took the light.
Jake:问题不大
Katrina: 我来烤吧
Katrina: I'll do the grilling.
Katrina: 你开吗给你录一下
Katrina: You open it, I'll record.
Lucia: 那我啃这个骨头了
Lucia: Then I'll gnaw on this bone.
Katrina: 跟你这样拍
Katrina: Take a shot like this.
Katrina: 拍高一点
Katrina: Shoot a bit higher.
Shure: 准备了吗
Shure: Ready?
Katrina: 嗯
Jake:给你打个灯
Jake: Let me get you a light.
Lucia: 小心小心
Lucia: Careful, careful.
Jake:慢点慢点慢点
Jake: Slowly, slowly, slowly.
Jake:给你打灯给你打灯
Jake: I'll shine the light for you.
Katrina: 哈哈哈笑死我了
Katrina: Hahaha, that's killing me with laughter.
Katrina: 你是某个那种晚会的
Katrina: Are you from some kind of party?
Jake:瓶下留人
Jake: Leave some for others.
Alice:有点干巴
Alice: It's a bit dry.
Alice:有没有那种油比较多的肉啊
Alice: Is there any meat with more fat?
Alice:开香槟
Lucia: 这串看起来有都差不多的样子
Lucia: This skewer looks pretty much the same.
Alice:买个串串吧
Alice: Let's buy a skewer.
Alice:怎么没声啊
Jake:跟火一样打不着
Jake: It's like a fire that won't start.
Shure: 开了吧
Shure: It's open, right?
Shure: 我就不信你今天靠气纯开不开
Shure: 他奶奶个腿的
Shure: Damn it.
Jake:看小飞行对不对吗
Jake: Look, isn't it the right flight?
Jake:是不是39
Jake: Is it 39?
Jake:块钱的就不行了
Jake: If it's 39 bucks, it won't work.
Shure: 不知道啊
Shure: I don't know.
Shure: 没开过 39块钱的呀
Shure: Never opened a 39 bucks one.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 他妈啤酒平时喝一杯还他妈40呢
Shure: A beer usually costs 40 bucks for a glass.
Shure: 好可以了
Shure: Alright, that's good.
Shure: 这回准备
Shure: This time, ready.
Shure: 321
Shure: 虽然很不优雅
Shure: Although it's not elegant.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Mm.
Jake:但是很成功
Jake: But it was successful.
Katrina: 去换他一下吧
Katrina: Go and switch with him.
Katrina: 感觉他一直靠我来考吧
Katrina: Feels like he's always relying on me.
Katrina: 就是翻一下就行是吧
Katrina: Just flip it, right?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Mm.
Katrina: 拿手翻还是拿夹子翻
Katrina: Use hands or tongs to flip?
Alice:手不会烫的
Alice: Hands won't get burned.
Katrina: 你去吃点吧
Katrina: You should eat something.
Katrina: 是拿这个翻吗
Katrina: 不如拿手吧
Katrina: Better use hands.
Shure: 这是夹碳的夹子
Shure: 拿筷子翻
Katrina: 哇这看起来好诱人啊
Katrina: Wow, this looks so tempting.
Shure: 这其实也差不多
Shure: It's actually almost the same.
Katrina: 这是牛的哪个部位
Katrina: 这感觉这肉好好
Shure: 是感觉这肉油不够吗
Shure: 要不然就再加点油去
Shure: 反正那是腌的
Shure: Anyway, it's pickled.
Katrina: 直接直接这样抹
Katrina: Just spread it directly.
Shure: 不是我直接那个
Shure: No, I'll just do it.
Shure: 再往里倒点
Shure: Pour a bit more in.
Katrina: 就感觉火不太旺
Katrina: Feels like the fire's not strong enough.
Katrina: 就一般就是你那个油滴下去之后
Katrina: Usually when the oil drips down...
Katrina: 他不会生个小火之类的
Katrina: It doesn't start a small fire or anything.
Katrina: 煽风点火
Katrina: Fan the flames.
Katrina: 根本不用翻
Katrina: No need to flip it.
Katrina: 都没烤熟呢
Katrina: It's not cooked yet.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Katrina: 我说好像还不用翻
Katrina: I said it doesn't need to be flipped yet.
Katrina: 现在这个翻一下
Katrina: Flip it now.
Shure: 咱就盐多防水水多放油
Katrina: 搞两片来不
Katrina: Should we do two slices?
Katrina: 放点歌听
Katrina: Let's play some music.
Katrina: 谁要先尝一块看看淡还是咸
Shure: 直接浇上吧
Shure: Just pour it on.
Alice:筷子给我一下
Katrina: 你直接当驻唱歌手吧
Alice:在这上面撒一点点油
Alice: Sprinkle a little oil on top.
Alice:再一点点就行
Alice: Just a little more.
Katrina: 来洒油吗
Shure: 这个应该能放下
Shure: This should fit.
Alice:没事没事
Alice: It's fine, it's fine.
Alice:好抖腕非常不错
Alice: Good wrist flick, very nice.
Shure: 跟没抖一样是吧
Shure: It's like you didn't even flick it, right?
Alice:我可没这么说
Katrina: 我帮你扇
Alice:没事
Alice: It's fine.
Shure: 把这个从这边吧要不
Shure: 哎呦我操
Shure: Oh crap!
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Shure: 嗯操
Shure: Hmm, crap.
Alice:不然你以为
Alice: What did you think?
Katrina: 眼泪收回
Katrina: Stop crying.
Katrina: 不管太多的累
Katrina: Doesn't matter how tired you are.
Katrina: 感谢你的出
Katrina: Thanks for your help.
Shure: 尝了吗这啤酒
Shure: Have you tried this beer?
Katrina: 好喝这啤酒还不错哎
Katrina: 再尝一个
Katrina: Try another one.
Katrina: 这个不行
Katrina: This one's no good.
Katrina: 没有我的
Katrina: Not as good as mine.
Katrina: 倒进去吗
Katrina: Pour it in?
Shure: 不是你先喝完这个
Shure: No, you finish this first.
Shure: 这不一口的事吗
Shure: It's just one gulp, right?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: 这又在这骗小姑娘呢
Katrina: 这好喝
Katrina: 嗯这还不错
Shure: 所以我们下次有哪些需要改进的
Shure: 比如说碳
Shure: For example, carbon
Katrina: 就是要早点
Katrina: Just need to be earlier.
Shure: 碳要再多一些是吗
Shure: Do we need more charcoal?
Shure: 碳的多一点
Shure: A bit more charcoal.
Shure: 就是买那种碎一点的碳是吧
Shure: So, we need to buy smaller pieces of charcoal, right?
Katrina: 碳
Katrina: Charcoal.
Alice:可以自己给它捣碎
Alice: You can crush it yourself.
Alice:碳是可以自己给它捣碎好的但我们今天没弄
Alice: You can crush it yourself, but we didn't do it today.
Alice:但我们今天没弄
Katrina: 碳是刚买的吗
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Katrina: 美团外送啊
Alice:咋没风了
Alice:用不着闻烟了
Shure: 这个最里面那个
Shure: The one inside.
Shure: 应该好吧
Shure: Should be good, right?
Katrina: 好像没那中间有点红的
Katrina: It seems a bit red in the middle.
Katrina: 这好了吗这肉
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 好了这是牛肉
Shure: Okay, this is beef.
Katrina: 牛排这是牛肉是吧
Katrina: This is steak, right?
Shure: 这是牛肉
Shure: This is beef.
Katrina: 反反正几分熟都能吃
Katrina: Anyway, you can eat it at different levels of doneness.
Katrina: 直接把哎
Katrina: Just put it, hey.
Katrina: 为什么这个这么软呀
Katrina: Why is this so soft?
Katrina: 还是说他本来就是这么软
Katrina: Is it supposed to be this soft?
Katrina: 别的是硬的
Katrina: The other parts are harder.
Katrina: 他为什么是软的
Katrina: Why is this soft?
Alice:放时间不太一样
Alice: The timing is different.
Alice:有个是刚上去
Alice: One just went up.
Katrina: 要不把它单独单独烤一下嘛
Katrina: How about we bake it separately?
Katrina: 要不要把这一块单独烤一下它好软
Katrina: Should we bake this piece separately? It's really soft.
Alice:感觉也就这一块熟了
Alice: Feels like only this piece is cooked.
Shure: 来
Shure: Come on.
Alice:其他都不太行
Alice: The rest aren't quite done.
Shure: 来来
Shure: Come on, come on.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Alice:放时间不太一样
Alice: The timing is different.
Katrina: 甜品组跟烧烤哦
Katrina: The dessert team and the barbecue, okay.
Katrina: 洒水是什么意思啊
Katrina: What does sprinkling water mean?
Alice:嗯让它旺一点
Alice: It makes it more lively.
Alice:然后不那么干吧
Alice: And it won't be so dry.
Katrina: 啊洒水
Katrina: Ah, sprinkle water.
Katrina: 洒水跟山峰都可以
Katrina: Sprinkling water and peaks are both fine.
Katrina: 让他忘一点
Katrina: To make it more lively.
Katrina: 然后加油也可以
Katrina: And then you can add some oil too.
Alice:对油是让它滴下去
Alice: Yes, the oil should drip down.
Alice:然后就会有点小火
Alice: Then there will be a small flame.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Katrina: 我感觉我真的是我用反面夹去
Katrina: I feel like I really used the wrong side.
Katrina: 因为这个夹的生肉
Shure: 来大厨
Katrina: 好吃
Lucia: 正好
Shure: 跟平时的味完全不一样
Shure: It tastes completely different from usual.
Shure: 但是我又不知道差在哪
Shure: But I still don't know what's different.
Katrina: 但我觉得挺好吃
Katrina: 就不用自己调料
Katrina: No need for your own seasoning.
Katrina: 拍点艺术照
Katrina: Take some artistic photos.
Katrina: 就这样远远看着你
Katrina: Just watching you from afar.
Katrina: 夹过去吗
Alice:嗯
Alice:是手机响了
Alice: The phone is ringing.
Katrina: 那你去拿
Katrina: Then you go get it.
Katrina: 我来烤肉
Katrina: 不是你手机响
Katrina: 怎么他突然就那个了
Katrina: Why did he suddenly...
Katrina: 你平时做饭吗
Katrina: Do you usually cook?
Alice:做
Katrina: 个人你比较熟练
Katrina: You're pretty skilled at this.
Alice:还行
Alice: Not bad.
Alice:你要你得让他把这个火生起来
Alice: You need to get the fire going.
Alice:但是你又不能让他那个火真的烧到肉
Alice: But you can't let the fire actually burn the meat.
Alice:因为那个肉一烧他就糊了
Alice: Because if the meat gets burned, it'll char.
Alice:就焦了对
Alice: It'll get burned, yeah.
Alice:所以不让他太高
Alice: So don't let it get too high.
Alice:但是火大一点比较好吃
Alice: But a bit more fire makes it taste better.
Katrina: 这边翻一下
Katrina: 这不用翻是吧
Alice:你羊肉喜欢吃肥的还是瘦的
Katrina: 瘦的
Katrina:  我们家我吃瘦肉我妈吃肥肉
Katrina: 这已经差不多了
Katrina: 不行还软软的
Alice:我在家做饭就够我自己的
Katrina: 你会做什么菜就是那种普通的炒菜都行
Katrina: 你是哪人来着郑州
Katrina: Where are you from again? Zhengzhou?
Alice:郑州对
Alice: Zhengzhou, right.
Katrina: 我舍友也是郑州
Katrina: My roommate is also from Zhengzhou.
Katrina: 郑州到武汉只要很近
Katrina: Zhengzhou to Wuhan is so close.
Katrina: 一个小时
Katrina: Just an hour.
Alice:因为我们那个信阳基本上就是挨着湖北
Shure: 这边差不多
Shure: This side is almost done.
Alice:中间几个差不多
Alice: The ones in the middle are about done.
Shure: 咱三就守着炉子吃
Shure: 然后给他们送屋去好吧
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Alice:中间这几个还勉强
Alice: The ones in the middle are just okay.
Alice:行你要不拿一个先尝一下
Alice: Okay, why don't you take one and try it first?
Alice:这边可以这边瘦的这个
Alice:这个再搁上吧
Alice:鸡翅给它放边上吧鸡翅巨难熟让它慢慢烤
Katrina: 哦
那要去拿点别的肉吗
Alice:嗯你看你想吃啥你放啥
Alice: Hmm, look, put whatever you want to eat.
Katrina: 这么多筷子笑死了
Katrina: 这什么时候
Alice:还有别的有签的那种吗
Katrina: 随便我们自己吃就行
Katrina: 没有带签的了
Katrina: No more sticks left.
Katrina: 那只能烤这个了
Katrina: 哎这容易掉
Alice:嗯没事
Alice: Hmm, it's fine.
Alice:一会用得搁到这上面
Alice: Put it on top of here later.
Katrina: 只能用这种大的
Alice:这偏偏待会搁到这上面
Katrina: 嗯你先把那边清空
Katrina: Hmm, clear that side first.
Alice:来赏你一块
Shure: 我来了我来了
Alice:你尝尝
Katrina: 这应该熟了
Katrina: 洒点水不我想尝试一下
Katrina: 就直接用手
Katrina: Just use your hands.
Alice:你就这样
Alice: Just like this.
Tasha: 然后然后你把这个边边一圈再挤一下
Tasha: Then, you squeeze around the edges again.
Katrina: 好玩
Alice:爽不爽
Shure: 应该差不多
Shure: That should be about right.
Katrina: 品鉴师
Katrina: 这应该熟了这个
Alice:熟不熟
Alice: Is it cooked?
Shure: 吃的好像还有点嫩
Shure: The food seems a bit undercooked.
Katrina: 这个
Katrina: This...
Shure: 熟了熟
Shure: It's cooked, it's cooked.
Shure: 可以了都拿上来吧
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Alice:这是比较早搁进去
Alice: This was put in earlier.
Katrina: 那边熏死人了
Shure: 这不能直接放
Shure: You can't just put it directly.
Shure: 它会漏下去
Shure: It will leak.
Shure: darling just kiss me slow on my own
Shure: Darling just kiss me slow on my own.
Alice:他们在里面玩啥呢
Katrina: 做了两三种好像
Katrina: They made two or three kinds it seems.
Katrina: 主要是杨靖康有点搞笑
Katrina: Mainly because Yang Jingkang is kind of funny.
Shure: 我就不不不喂你俩了
Shure: I'm not, not, not feeding you both.
Katrina: 自己夹就是了
Shure: 每次都抱一双新筷子
Shure: Every time I grab a new pair of chopsticks,
Shure: 然后发现哎
Shure: then I realize, oh,
Shure: 我刚才有筷子
Shure: I already had chopsticks.
Shure: 来大厨随便吃点吧
Katrina: 自己烤的就是好吃
Shure: 自己家孩子怎么看都好看
Alice:我觉得这个差不多了
Katrina: 嗯这个可以
Katrina: 他吃吧
Shure: 你吃
Alice:这个差不多给
Alice: This is almost...
Shure: 谢谢大厨
Shure: Thanks, chef.
Shure: 怎么样跳一段会吗
Shure: How about a little dance?
Katrina: 哼
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina: 不会这个歌吗你会跳
Katrina: Don't you know this song? Can you dance to it?
Shure: 不是我说这个
Shure: No, I mean this.
Katrina: 嗯不会
Katrina: Hmm, no.
Katrina: 你会
Katrina: Can you?
Shure: 要学吗
Shure: Want to learn?
Katrina: 又会跳舞又会唱歌又会弹吉他牛啊
Katrina: Can dance, sing, and play guitar, that's awesome.
Katrina: 嗯好
Katrina: Okay.
Shure: 我也忘了那叫什么舞了反正
Shure: I forgot what that dance is called anyway.
Katrina: 好吃
Katrina: Delicious.
Alice:给
Alice: Here.
Alice:应该差不多了
Alice: It should be almost done.
Katrina: 拿碟过来不
Shure: 碟来了
Shure: 你碟来了
Shure: 这几个都好了吗
Alice:熟了吧
Shure: 应该都熟了
Shure: It should be all done.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Shure: 你们吃吧
Shure: You guys eat.
Alice:抖了一
Alice: Shaking.
Shure: 看着都是一样的步骤
Katrina: 母爱吧
Shure: 哈哈哈别玩尬的好吗哥们